cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com what do you think about like
giving kids access to the uh Tick Tock
the internet how are you looking at that
well I thought vivek's answer at the
debate did you see that was was pretty
sure actually so they asked him in the
debate uh because he got he had been
talking about banning Tick Tock for
about a year and then apparently he hung
out with Jake Paul and Jake Paul
convinced him to get on Tick Tock so
Vivek said well I want to get young
voters and the Republican Party always
loses so we have to get where they are
but then when I'm in office I'll ban it
and no one under 16 should be on social
media and it's like well first off who
gives the president of the United States
the right to say who can be on social
media and what age you can be that's a
really Bizarro
um authoritarian tendency that he said
right there but that's sort of the ends
justify the means kind of thing like do
you want to use Chinese spyware and
encourage people to be on Chinese
spyware so that the day you get the
power you can ban the Chinese spyware uh
so no I do not I personally don't have
Tick Tock I did not want to use it on my
show at all my man Brock over here uh my
social media guy he wanted us to be on
there I said you are I am not pressuring
you at all I said if you want a burner
phone to put it on and block you go
ahead and he did that but but I yeah I
want nothing to do with it makes at it
backwards you don't ban kids from social
media although I think kids shouldn't be
on social media but that should be up to
the parent but it should it should be
that we criminally charge people who
post say like porn on Twitter so if
you're a person who was on Twitter and
you post pornographic material then it
should be Elon Musk and it should be the
person who posted it who are criminally
charged for posting you're talking about
illegal porn or porn but wait you're
saying that's how it should be right now
I mean so you want Elon Musk to be held
account for some for for legal porn
that's on the planet yes I do but so
let's put it so you have a disagreement
with just policy with him because he
said it's fine right so imagine uh you
own a bookstore and that's all it is to
bookstore but you know that a lot of the
books in the store are graphic
hardcore pornography and you allow
children in guess what's going to happen
yeah if you if you have an adult
bookstore and you allow children in the
police are going to come and you are
going to get in serious trouble so you
want some basic parental rules around
Twitter I actually don't know what I
have no idea I'm singling out Twitter
kind of as it's the shock value to say
Elon Musk right but the reality is
my question and we've talked about quite
a bit how did we get to the point in
society where we've decided that we have
the internet which is effectively public
streets and you know what you might ask
your 10 year old to go run to the store
and pick up a thing of some milk right
right it's no big deal but then there's
someone standing in the street corner
and they're waving around a big picture
of adults in hardcore adult activities
the kid sees it freaks out anybody who
sees it they call the police guess what
the police are going to do they're gonna
arrest that guy and they're gonna say
you violated a whole bunch of public
looted lewd and and lascivious laws
indecent exposure Etc
but the internet which functions
essentially is similar in a similar way
it's a public space where people can
post things there's no repercussions for
any of these businesses to allow minor
children the age of 13 and even younger
to access things that would otherwise be
illegal to distribute so if Twitter had
the same regulations related to age that
I guess PornHub has or something where
you have to click something you'd be
okay with that meaning you yeah okay but
you're saying as long as there's some
system in place where I just don't know
what the deal you want to recollection
when I signed onto Twitter do you have
to say yeah you want to go to an adult
bookstore you walk in and say ID please
you show them your ID and say okay now
you're old enough to be in here right
that's because we don't want kids going
into adult bookstores Twitter should be
the same if you if you post lewd and
lascivious adult activities
should put a blur over the image and
then only people who have verified IDs
can view
these these controlled images right it's
interesting because Elon has a different
policy on this than you can't do that on
Facebook right I haven't been on
Facebook in years I have no freaking
clue but I'm sure you can right yeah I'm
pretty sure uh no actually but it's
extremely borderline so when you're on
Facebook and Instagram it's it's you
know uh women with wet t-shirts on and
you could pretty much see everything but
therefore it is not her being naked it's
still somehow alone
to a lot of people you can't put porn on
Instagram but you can but you can but uh
it's not explicit so there's there's a
lot of tricks they do to get around it
yes one of the tricks they do is they're
uh when on Instagram you have to do the
Mosaic where you upload a bunch of
pictures and then it it makes your feed
it creates the oh yeah yeah so oh so
each individual photo is not but all
together they it's right they got the
tricks right they got the tricks but my
point is simple I am not literally
saying I believe in the moral absolute
position that you know we must do these
things I'm saying if it is the standard
right now to say kids can't drink kids
can't look at porn you need an ID to
enter the establishment why don't we
have those same restrictions how did the
internet come to be that we just assume
as a society it should not have these
safeguards for children probably because
it was a lot of it was built by 16 year
olds like sitting in their room I think
it was because it was never taken
seriously because in the early days of
the internet they were just like it was
the Wild West nobody knew what the hell
but it was nobody used it yeah we're now
at the point of ubiquity the internet is
everything and we've not stopped to ask
ourselves are we okay with creating
public highways in public streets where
children can get access to graphic
murder snuff and hardcore porn be honest
I know I'm okay with the highways being
there we just need to police them
properly because if you go after the
network for something that happens on
the network you'll end up crashing the
whole system but this is my point the
person who posts it but the solution
there is I don't think we should ban
porn I think the way Twitter and every
platform should work is if you post it
it is blurred and you can't see it
unless you verified your your age
YouTube sort of does this but they don't
have any real like YouTube will age
restrict certain content but all you
have to do is log in and claim you're a
certain age you don't need an idea no no
or or you could you know shove things up
you know what and still be on YouTube
and that's totally fine well there was a
question yeah yeah there was a
particular video that we can't even more
than once describe that's allowed and
all those other type of approval YouTube
had videos with millions of hits called
what's in my bum where they would show
people and then they'd have to guess
what was and I'm like
this is not not just items but other
individuals right pornography has been
individual yeah yeah but I mean
pornography has been there were other
people yes yes yes what are you saying
well it's still there that's like a
what are you talking about don't
get any ideas here ribbon uh calm your
horses there okay sir uh another human
being was inside of another I can't
family-friendly show for the members
pornography has been weaponized
militaries have used it against
populations how do you handle that
without destroying free speech I think
is is something that I think is is worth
looking into but I think we should
always try to prioritize uh freedom of
speech without violating and destroying
and running a fifth generational Warfare
program on the future of this country as
of course it's not just Tick Tock it's
not just Instagram it's Hollywood it's
Corporate America it's BlackRock it's
the ESG score it's the banks that are
all working in tandem destroying the
children of this country and you know I
I I want to agree with you Tim but I
think uh when it comes to your kind of
white pill moment here it could it could
go either way because if we look at the
kids of kellyanne Conaway you look at
her daughter you look at Elon Musk he
has a non-binary child how in the world
did that happen yeah right you could
lose your kids you could also lose your
your kids to the state with CPS being
overly aggressive and going after
parents and and also a abusing and
hurting children and other unspeakable
ways so I think the fight is there how
do you handle it without giving the
government more authority over you I
think is the question that I want to
answer well I think Tim without
belaboring the point I don't think you
really want to go into all of the
companies and force them to do all sorts
of things but it sounds like to me you
want at least the internet service
providers to have a little more uh
control over things right because Elon
is running a private company so to me he
can do what my personal belief is he can
do what he wants with it no I disagree
yeah you don't think he can do what he
wants with it no I think no he if he's
13 year olds at a bar no no we within
the confines of the law right right I
think he's within the confines of Law
and that's where we're getting I guess
he's not well then it is illegal to run
a business that delivers pornographic
materials to Children Elon Musk is doing
that
I guess under the way you're saying it
it's not under the way I'm saying it's
like no I just don't know I'll take your
word for I just don't know exactly what
the sign up process is on all that stuff
but so I believe what you're saying I
think because you need a bank account I
signed on it 12 years ago I have no idea
any internet access you need to have a
bank account you can't a kid can't get
internet access that's not true no no I
don't well you're talking about Twitter
itself just a service that is quote
unquote free you you can't like the fact
that these platforms exist and outright
say you have to be at least 13 or 13
years old to use it means okay fine your
parents can drive a kid a kid can't get
to the adult bookstore because it's 10
miles away so as parents drive him there
but then they say yeah they drop them
off around the corner they don't know
what he's doing the kid goes into an
adult bookstore and there there is Mark
Zuckerberg and Elon Musk being like hey
you're 13 you're good to look at all
this stuff don't worry about it I don't
understand how that how that is you
gotta have sensitive filters but it's
hard to make sure that they always work
and like to destroy the network because
one of them got through it was a risky
problem is is the argument that we've
come to in society where we've decided
that porn should be available to
children
is that is that is that the argument no
that's not my argument no I mean my
point is like no one no one will
disagree right it is a fact if you go to
an adult bookstore they say you need an
ID to come in otherwise we'll be
breaking the law yeah the internet
quite literally has porn websites they
and and kids can go to them without any
restrictions and when when uh laws were
proposed to require IDs or porn websites
these porn websites said no they were
like how dare you because you know a lot
of these companies that that run ads I
bet a lot of these kids a lot of their
views come from children the joke I made
on Twitter is when you're on the
internet no one knows you're 14. because
a lot of these politicians like you'll
see you'll see you know insert
politician arguing with someone I'm like
you're 40 and that person you're
responding to is probably 14. but how
many of these businesses get their money
off of viewership not direct pay and
like they're running weird ads or
whatever and those kids generate ads so
my point is simply this either we agree
that we have never
allowed children to go to adult
bookstores and we must maintain that
same standard in all areas of the public
which means Twitter must immediately
restrict this stuff or we agree that
you know what we've evolved as a society
we now think children should have access
to adult material thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time